[Music]
yes
yes yes yes yes today we're watching
the reddit yeah we're watching should i
redo the intro not
for when they knew dave sent me this
read it i'm really excited about it
because it seems really funny
now i shall have my sip i like this we
have a rare
subreddit that no one else has reviewed
i'm the first one to review this
and it's really funny let's freaking do
this
should i explain the joke before yeah
all right well the title is
they knew basically something that seems
like a coincidence
but it's like nah they knew they knew
what they were doing you know
that's the subreddit go ahead zap me
absorbing lightning's
totally my thing you never had black
lightning before
what the [ __ ]
they definitely knew
[Laughter]
yeah they knew architect will be like
you know what would be really cool
you hate to shoot them from the top it
would be epic
trust me thank you god damn right they
knew
amazon echo frames glasses lets alexa
sit
on your face they knew they knew what
they were doing with that title
the owner of my airbnb has a dog named
kevin
human sounding name terrified me at
first wait what i apologize in advance
but kevin may try to sleep with you
just keep your torch
come on you can't just drop kevin may
sleep with you
all right yeah board employee knew he
definitely knew
yo 68.90 they knew they knew and they
were wrong
wait is this a swedish one yeah it is
come on sweden i love what you guys are
doing keep up the good work
what
oh god oh it took me so long
sorry my brain became brain understand
my middle name is kevin all right don't
use his name as an acronym because they
yeah got it and plus um
that's i feel like they should know
better they should
know is that i read it they should not
come on
on the last day of his death let us
never forget the robot that drew the
first dick pic on another planet
a legend nasa knew nasa be like all
right here are the coordinates for his
last journey
trust me it will be epic it will get
many upvotes on reddit
keanu reeves might even give it a thumbs
up that's an official nasa photo by the
way
murphy's law states that the best way to
get the right answer
on the internet is not to ask a question
it's to post the wrong answer
what are some examples where you apply
this law
i keep hearing murphy's law and i never
remember what it is and it
annoys me so much what is it i suppose
love nature
expressed in various human popular
things anything that can go wrong will
go wrong
it's so lame that doesn't even make
sense oh
[Laughter]
no
this is cunningham's law and not
murphy's law
murphy's law is anything that can go
wrong will go wrong
i just got played so hard i've seen this
before
refinance your home and pay no
they knew they knew come on graphic
designer actually i don't think they
knew because a lot of times you don't
actually
if it's html or whatever they probably
don't actually put that you
ah well done snickers they definitely
knew
so what difference is that that's that's
pretty negative natural blue
nature bubble necklace negligible
that's pretty negligible negligible
negligible dick thunder
what well done parents our last name is
thunder what should we name him
dick dick is such a great name
underrated people think it's like
embarrassed to be called dick no it's a
privilege
it's a goddamn privilege and a right
mask you put on
mess up utah or masji
well i know what i read dumbasses
let's not forget that rapunzel was
quarantined and met her future husband
so let's think positive here so right
now
go google the name of the kingdom
entangled oh my god it already shows up
google knew what
there's some edgy jokes in here i
appreciate that uh
they knew they definitely knew nice
you know god damn well they knew they
knew
olay miss accidentally puts he started
on cumps
honoring healthcare worker they knew
they knew that there are no accidents
that's that mean
that's the subreddit there are no
accidents yeah that's the subreddit i
knew
i know it come a little closer it's an
ad for effing funeral services
they knew they have no clients
uh when you think you're dope but
actually you're just a pedo they didn't
know they definitely did not know
they did not know i dictate who knows
and who doesn't
he has risen they did not know they know
it's not
lesson 69 come
they may or may not know but either way
epic
well done don't touch yourself ask the
staff
thank you they clearly did not know stop
posting the wrong
idiots chick dig guys that eat out
they definitely knew the 90s was a wild
[ __ ] time everything was sexually
oriented
listen to all the songs you listen as a
kid and we listen to the lyrics
and you tell me there's no sexual uh
innuendo
mattress protector waterproof wait what
happy valentine's day oh yeah they knew
yeah they do julia roberts finds
life and her holes get bigger with age
correction or roles thank you well done
can you imagine spending time on an
interview and this is the headline you
get out of it
and you know her management wrote to me
like you need to correct this
i like that correction takes like
headline bam correction we just quit
that it was just put the correction in a
little
snape ejaculated slughorn i know to all
aspiring novelists
sometimes you should just use said snape
he nutted
uh thanks jk rowling snape blood
where the [ __ ] is slughorn
oh i i ship it all right
i'm here pakistan government
accidentally turns cat filter on during
fb
live leaves everyone in splits they knew
you don't accidentally turn on a filter
well done pakistan well done
not a good way to honor her still ended
up at the back of the bus
huh but the thought of this she could
save her
from the back of the bus but now i i i
feel uncomfortable with joking about
this i'm just going to move on
forget how edgy reddit is sometimes
please don't counsel me
i don't condone any jokes i never even
made a joke oh god wait no wait what ah
get your throat game ready what am i
supposed to read here house gotta chill
oh my god they put the thing next to the
thing house
that's smart that's the wings how to
adjust the tow bar
in a range rover not even joking oh
hell yeah make sure you get a firm grip
on that
tow bar make sure
oh god i can't even look at that there's
some coke with molly
they knew they knew as a vending machine
real field person
it has to be a career highlight the
caption made that funnier
pop your cherry what does that mean i
still understand that expression like it
makes no sense
well done you knew you knew and i
respect you
so much they did not think through this
water fan
they did and they knew and some would
say they thought too much
you know whoever designed this
microphone to be this shape
they knew all right yeah and the fact
that it sounds better the closer i get
to it microphone designers
you knew all right you knew all right
i'm just saying that you knew why does
it sound better when it's inside my
mouth
like this [ __ ] makes no sense you knew
you dirty
oh my god
[Laughter]
it took me so long i was like wait what
oh
short of the month and you select me
this will not be forgotten
you knew calendar of game of thrones
well done
that's smart oh my god yeah i read weed
too it's supposed to say
emma like this way
it looks
yes well done well done cake makers
what is this i don't get it oh sh
if you read the reflection the word
becomes a different thing
well done well done graphic designers
you know what would be cool
if that water reflect itself with the
thought
yeah suit yourself no [ __ ] yourself
stop working start jerking eat your
family first
for 20. nice have you ever had sexual
intercourse
yes no six nine hey
hey my man that's the number don't you
love
the feeling of nice smooth balls in your
hand poke balls that is
a sex joke in their pokemon that's
awesome that's so cool
wowie disney erects giant woody
all right stop it
nice uh you knew
you knew you dirt are these old oh my
god can we get some normal ones please
chris banks family someone stop chris
someone stop him
oh god i'm gonna deal with the devil he
took my legs but i still think it was
worth it
absolutely why do you think i don't have
mine huh yeah
saudi arabia accidentally prints
textbooks showing yoda sitting next to
the king
what the actual saudi arabia that's
legendary
how did that happen i'm so confused they
knew i've seen this before
do you like it in your face yes i like
it in any
place the dog is my expression
alexa play my jazz favorite playlist
alexa turn off the lights
they did let's get this over with
quickly jazz
they knew i knew
we can speed run this three minutes come
on alexa
how do you print that banner
cook me yeah they alright i'm sick of
that i've seen enough sexual innuendos
to know what else is gonna coming i did
not know
i did not know i didn't know all right
guys thanks for watching this episode
make sure you are subscribed
to uh hit the bell it's free
and uh sick us tomorrow however become
member
it all goes to charity so thank you
[Music]